Leorio is so much more powerful than you
know too often he gets played off as a
joke but very few people stop to
consider the magnitude of what this man
can do Leorio has a purpose to fulfill
in this series that no other protagonist
can do the Fulfillment of a power that
no other can access Leorio is going to
change the world and here's how firstly
Leorio has oh yes he's had something of
a turbulent presence in Hunter Hunter he
was originally intended to be one of the
main cast members of the series one of
the four Hunter dude guys would have all
sorts of Adventures whilst doing the
hunting it was going to be the you
Hakusho model for unlikely friends
versus the world but then toga she went
yeah nah and over the next two decades
repeatedly changed his mind about
exactly what he wanted the story to be
and the sad truth is that Leorio had no
role in most of these Tales the
character was simply the wrong side dish
to accompany togashi's A5 grade stake
story but you know what they say every
potato has its day in my mouth and the
time has finally come for Leorio to
shine and it's not something he's
unprepared for either there's
misconception hunt that Leorio is weak
because he's a gag character who has
never actually done any of the punch
fighting but ever since day one Leorio
has demonstrated superhuman speed
agility durability and even raw strength
through the very fact that he was even
able to survive the hunter exam to begin
with he's a lot stronger than you think
and that is especially true in the manga
during the zaldic family Arc La Oreo
opened the second testing gate all on
his own with an accompanying Grill sound
effect meanwhile the the scrubs gone in
kilowatt they could only open the first
door on their own but both the 1999 and
2011 anime change this and downplayed
layer of strength likely because they
knew just how rapidly he was going to
slide into irrelevancy eventually
Togashi himself even took away leora's
trademark switchblade thus killing his
one and only catchphrase which was you
mess with the dock you get stabbed in
the car the tagashi could have just left
it there Leorio look he was an
unfortunate offcut however Togashi like
any good Dogo saw this offcut on the
floor and said to himself yes and
delicious there is a reason why Leorio
is currently in involved in the
succession War not only that but there
is an even bigger reason why he was
chosen to go to the Dark Continent and
Beyond even that Leorio has one final
purpose to fulfill in the end game of
Hunter Hunter something that absolutely
nobody else can do but first I am
wearing a jacket now but also a question
have you ever wanted to dress your dog
up like some sort of maniacal Flamingo
and turn him into a Scottish Lord
because I have as did the sponsor of
this video established titles a Project
based on a historic Scottish custom
whereby landowners are referred to as
leads Lords or ladies in English and you
can officially change your name to Lord
or lady on stuff like credit cards is
amazing and I have invoked this mighty
mighty power to have my anime villain
dog officially declared as a lord it's
alright here on this shockingly official
Proclamation title packs give you at
least one square foot of dedicated land
with a unique plot number on a private
estate in edleston Scotland it's a great
last minute gift for loved ones or even
just semi-liked ones also I've been told
that everyone who uses my link will get
a plot next to each other so we could
probably build some sort of
scottish-based Hunter Association it's
also a fun novel way to preserve the
nature of Scotland because established
titles plants a tree with every order
and works with global Charities on
restoration efforts go to
establishtitles.com to shop their Black
Friday sales with an additional 10 off
using Code new world and help support
the channel starting from the 10th of
October but now it's back to you me and
the first part of his journey is like
most strongly rooted in the world of nen
Leorio is not a bad net user in fact
he's so not bad that I would even go so
far as to describe him as good his
learning was yes a little self-delayed
but his progress since embracing the art
form has been nothing short of
astounding and it makes sense because
Leorio is a perfect nen candidate in
this world Aura manifests as a direct
response to desire that's why Network
crafted the hunter exam to be as brutal
as it is to make sure that only the
people who have that superhuman Drive
make it through and leoria's drive is of
course to help people when he was but a
small layorioling his friend died from a
condition that was entirely curable
however they couldn't afford the
necessary Medical Care his friend's name
was Pietro in the 1999 anime but I I
don't know why both the 2011 anime and
the manga keep him nameless so that
that's just the thing but another thing
is the key thing to remember about
Leorio which is that he is not a one in
a million and talent like gone and kill
nor is he a recklessly driven Genius
Like karapika particularly in the case
of gon and krapika their chosen nen
Parts have been to burn twice as bright
for half as long so they present
astounding short-term progress but at
the cost of quite literally their lives
Leorio however is in the nen game for
the Long Haul his progress is slower
than his friends but it's made in a much
more sustainable way for example it was
pretty funny when leoria rocked up at
York New City knowing nothing about nen
but whether he knew it or not the
objectively correct path for his nen
Journey was to stock up on medical
knowledge first because if leoria loans
Nan without understanding how to
actually use it for his goals then he
just end up creating a series of
half-baked abilities so as much as he
seemingly fell behind due to
prioritizing medicine the knowledge base
he built has allowed him to catch shop
at an incredibly rapid rate to the point
where leorio's net abilities even
impressed Jinx Freaks and impressing
Jing is a feat that even gone never
managed to accomplish and I think it's
even more impressive considering that
leora's natural subclass is a mission I
know that enhances they're usually
consider the kind of boring and
undesirable class what do you do oh I
hit things I mean to be fair they hit
things like like pretty hard but
throughout the series it seems like
emitters usually end up as you know like
the scum lingering at the bottom of the
ninpool for example famous emitters
include Franklin barovada and pockel so
essentially all of the characters known
for going with their Aura because that's
as far as most natural emitters get it's
at the point where I am certain the only
reason why razer's shoulders are so
broad is because he literally carries
the entire emission subclass you know
compared to a lot of his admit to
contemporaries Leorio is actually very
impressive with the creative spin he's
put on the category basically the Aurora
mission is its kind of man emission
tends to be at its best when it's used
in conjunction with one of its
neighboring categories and it's used
particularly well with its bestest body
manipulation Nation because that leads
very smoothly into the realm of
nenbeasts you emit the nenbeast and then
you manipulate the ninbeast and that's
quite a benefit for Leorio actually
because in theory he could just emit his
own series of medical assistants
programmed with all sorts of incredibly
mechanically precise uses however Leorio
is already far more advanced than we
give him credit for for example his
ultrasound ability is essentially an
advancement of the end principle it
covers a smaller potential area but it's
extremely difficult for opponents to
detect as opposed to a standard end
which is perfect for Leora because he
obviously lacks the AHA shall we say the
more conventional qualities of say
strengthened sheer Aura quantity but he
doesn't need any of that well he needs
some of it he doesn't need much of that
because leora's main weapon is knowledge
he may not have much Aura but he
understands the most efficient way to
make use of what he has and in the case
of ultrasound that provides Leora with
information whilst completely masking
his presence from all but the top tier
nen users of the world and he also does
have a wide range of attacking options
remote punches are obvious one again
perfect for layario because allows him
to attack without making himself
vulnerable in close combat plus it
increases the overall force of his
attacks beyond that of a normal punch
with the added travel velocity if Leorio
could ask his other neighbor enhancement
for a cup of nen sugar then these
punches could be devastating and hey
maybe they already are Leorio obviously
had no intention to kill a seriously
injaging so what we saw there could
definitely be on the weakest side
probably the ability to take most note
of though are the phasing bullets after
dissecting leora's power Jing used these
on a much much larger scale but the
intent behind them was to send a
concentrated burst of hostile Laura to
destroy impossible to reach tumors and
blood clots within the body and as soon
as I read that I I could feel my insides
like viscerally squirming because in the
wrong hands and even with a teeny tiny
bit of aura that could be instant death
to anyone I mean the human heart has
what like like around 10 veins going
through it so all someone needs to do is
send a couple of Pew pews targeting
those veins and you are gone not to
mention the insane damage you could do
to the brain all with effectively
microscopic quantities of War and
microscopic quantities of ore is one of
the few bars that Leorio does clear but
it's also nigh on impossible to imagine
him using nen to actually hurt anyone
because it goes against the core
principle behind his Drive in fact not
using the abilities in a hostile way
might even be a condition for how leoro
has managed to concoct such Advanced
powers in such a short amount of time
but even if not something I always come
back to is Melody's description of
leoria Melody once said that Leorio had
the nicest heartbeat in the entirety of
York New City so when it comes down to
it I just don't think that Leorio is
capable of killing or even seriously
injuring and this compassion is a common
trait amongst emitters which can also be
seen in Knuckles much Kinder approach to
Beast hunting and even the soft-hearted
melody herself is a natural emitter with
a goal to find a dangerous piece of
music in order to prevent anyone else
from being cursed by it but one does not
need to kill or even injure to become a
dangerous and Force if anything Leorio
could combine his medical and his net
knowledge to figure out a way to shut
off his opponent's Aura nodes
essentially placing them in a state of
four setsu making the not only
defenseless but much more relevant for
Leorio attackless with the right Mentor
Leora could mix nen and medicine or I
suppose nenison to become truly great
and conveniently enough he just so
happens to have the best possible Mentor
he could wish for with cheetah she is a
Triple Star disease Hunter and almost
certainly the highest authority of
medical Aureus in the world so he's
definitely on the right path however
currently he doesn't quite have the
luxury of learning at his own rate but
you know what pressure creates diamonds
and Leorio has three tasks to accomplish
before the end of Hunter Hunter the
first is during the succession war and
it's all about Kurapika our blonde men
is on a guaranteed path of
self-destruction whether he gets killed
during the war by the Phantom troop or
even by his own then abilities karate
because life nuts are well and truly
stuck in this device but Leorio is not
going to let him die he's already
watched his childhood friend die
helplessly he also almost watched gondai
again helplessly so this time around
leoria was going to be able to save his
friend his one driving purpose in life
is to heal those who need it and
karapika is at the very front of that
emergency room line Leorio is the kilowa
to karapik is gone although he's more
like a fusion of gone and kiloway you
know gone's abrasiveness with Killer's
loyalty but that is by far the least
interesting event to come out of leora's
future because this boy is also headed
to the Dark Continent and for the
longest time I was like okay Togashi
we're taking the weakest burst and
plonking them into the strongest
possible place what what is your game
here Mr story man and then it hit me
Leorio is going to the Dark Continent
because he is the one who is going to
bring back a substance that
revolutionizes Humanity whether it's one
we already know like Nitro rice or
metallion that would radically change
medicine or even something completely
new maybe even unrelated to Medicine
Leora could find a breakthrough in any
field make like a gazillion dollars and
then just dedicate his entire Fortune to
Medicine he could quite literally become
the richest man in the world which was
very much his ambition becoming a hunter
in the first place and with that in mind
leorio's end game position in the series
will be to become the chairman of the
hunter Association a position that he
has admit they already turned down but
layario's whole character Arc with him
tagashi intended it or not has been
about the Slow Burn Cheadle herself even
stated that leoria would likely make a
fantastic chairman she honestly believes
that he would lead the organization onto
a better path and if she as the current
chairman is mentoring him then cheetah
is more or less grooming him for
eventual leadership let's put it this
way he is already the most popular
hunter in the association he's already a
member of The Zodiacs so he's one step
away he already has the support of many
of the zodiacs including the current
chairman and if he returns from a dark
continent with with literally anything
that isn't a Calamity then he will be
heralded as the greatest hunter in all
of the history after which point Leora
will do exactly what he said during the
chairman election if I become chairman
I'll use the association for my own
personal ends my first order to all of
you will be to do something to save God
except substitutes they've gone for just
people in general and then and then
there's also this one little extra
tidbit the lurking Calamity that is gyro
a man made up of pure malevolence and
evil most people believe that if and
when Jairus story plays out it's going
to be gone who inevitably needs to stop
him however Gyro's natural opposite is
Leorio the man with the nicest heartbeat
taking on the man I guess not even man
the most horrific heartbeat ownings the
monster thing so that's what gyro is he
doesn't have Humanity anymore Leorio is
a natural counter because his pursuit of
medicine stands directly against jairo's
strategy of spreading drugs throughout
the world and poisoning Humanity That
Way Gone can't do anything about that
but Leorio can which would only cement
his position as the world's future most
recognized Hunter and the final
protagonist of Hunter Hunter and thanks
again to established titles for
sponsoring this video